a lot of the people here did not expect
him to play and now he comes away with a
leather larceny back the other way
you could see right away when he left it
hands but it started on the defensive
end
because of his
shot clock at three cold roll poke
defense
what a shot signing of the offseason for
phoenix
but there's playing from behind what a
pass by kawhi
leonard and what a finish from avitza's
hubba
montrez and mr mellow and lou williams
out there for
doc rivers and the clippers are going to
get this offense kick started
shamit with a great look knocks it in
and a very nice play again right there
kawhi
charlotte means business here tonight in
l.a
[Applause]
good feed from kauai in a finger roll
finish for montrez harold
[Applause]
with a little bit of english off the
window head man the basketball right
there you look at kawhi leonard nice
little hesitation
oh a little oopsie doo sink his talons
into the loose ball drives in on zubat
snow
kawaii with the outlet to shamit behind
the defense and lays it in plumber
played by landry shemet
[Music]
so great in that first quarter
kawhi i'll tell you there you see the
line
he has not disappointed in his clipper
debut
here is kawaii swiveling to the cup oh a
sledgehammer follows
let him operate in this area where he's
very good
nice spin-off spin i cut out the spin
cycle
[Applause]
and this dude is this dude is so good
[Applause]
patterson try with a little one-toed
spin to the baseline all of his shots
have been little mid-range jumpers and
he's put the clippers out in front by
through a couple of nice plays in this
first quarter that maybe don't go into
the stat sheet
kawaii's had a few of them that do
trying to do another one right there and
he knocks it in
you see how good this player ciacom lays
it in with the right hand
[Applause]
what a pass by leonard and another
finish inside
six points in 24 seconds for james hart
leonard working on rivers beautiful shot
over rivers to get to he's so good again
at finding ways to
even against double teams get into the
paint
leonard starting to heat up that's two
in a row here in the second quarter for
kawhi leonard
should be the norm leonard for three
good foul count
it the four-point opportunity the
clippers have the lead for the first
time
and the owner loves it and telegraph
that pass
beverly in the corner
kawhi leonard
some of the matchups to start former
teammates russell westbrook right now
guarding paul george
leonard got hit shot skirt and one
has got length strength and plenty of
game and
falling away no problem through contact
i mean how you know listen the strength
of his hands
[Applause]
[Music]
kawhi with five first quarter points
gets it through a wide open heartless
foot three that's such an important shot
there's open threes in the corner
last night in utah the pelicans trailed
by 18 at about this moment in the second
quarter as well make it a cool 20
as kawhi leonard knocks down his fourth
shot
leonard down the lane muscles up a shot
by the right hand his second bucket of
the night
tomorrow night they'll be in memphis
take on the grizzlies
elevates and pounds it
the post up and the sudden quick move
that time no three or four dribbles
just a quick turn to that left shoulder
and then
the body moves
pocket pick kawhi off to the races
checks his rear view
and casually throws it in with the right
hand
and that my friends is the candles on
the cake
kawhi leonard with 31 stage here for doc
rivers with 6 17 to play
and a nice ovation more horsemen for the
clippers mantras harold lew williams off
the bench 23 and 22 but coach smith
tries to get it to his streaking
troy brown back to kauai and he pounds
it in with the right hand comes down
on parker but appears to be all right
shout out those 11 games with the hand
injury leonard hits nothing but
forward and it's a 12 point lead again
question will be by how much
[Applause]
leonard on carter he's got the size
advantage gets into the pain and puts it
down
[Applause]
they reset it back up to kawhi he'll
shoot over heart
of three and it goes net never moved why
leonard mack got off to a
slow shooting start to ben mclemore
talking about shooting right absolutely
talking about anything else he doesn't
hit rim
[Music]
boos rained down on kauai leonard i'm
not sure he really cares all that much
how about heartless at corner three
right here if you're the clippers you've
got to find a way to get a basket
boy sees the mismatch on aldridge and
skates right to the right
and it's always nice when you can come
down and especially in this building
while they're booing him he's going to
want to be aggressive like
[Applause]
seven points in three minutes for kyle
kuzma kali leonard answers right back
with his second three-pointer
leonard an aggressive drive oh my
look out below possession right here for
the clippers
[Applause]
hawaii has 34. an aggressive drive oh
kawhi knows if he comes off a screen
they're double teaming
so turn down the screen and go dunk on
whoever's in the paint
that was a big time play by a big time
player brian
i'll tell you what we see that every
once in a while from kauai those strong
drives we've seen a few times tonight
first shuffle
into zubats look out another nice play
and avitza's zubot's rewarded
this is a match up you like right now
you got jamal murray on kauai
and kawhi leonard makes him pay i mean
anytime you see that match up if you're
kawhi leonard you're saying okay
sex to the strong drive oh not this time
says
[Applause]
leonard says let me show you how it's
done and he punches it in home cooking
lofty thompson great defense by zoo the
clippers have time kawhi is aware
down the lane down the hatch counted on
a foul
she made this deal he saw the clock and
he battled through the traffic he used
his strength
on these two defenders someone might
need to give colin sexton the hugs
tell him it's not your fault leonard
trying to do the same thing
fly baby fly right here
the quick jab brandon knight from the
initial possession
lost his footing and kawhi leonard
calibrated that move
will play on wednesday night zion
williamson you'll see it on
espn as leonard gets the cross court
fine from beverly
hiley and one this is just a great move
see
they got the switch and as soon as he
saw ball was on him even though ball is
tall he just gave him the fade away
now that's what makes
great ball moving got a part
of ingram and will get a little room
service at the other end now he gets a
gun away with a little bumper
it's around shemel anthony smith has his
three blocked by kawhi
what a blocked shot right there and then
back the other way
look out below oh my goodness
curry for one and then blocks a shot and
then gets out
and one dunks the basketball on
luka doncic i mean what a
couple plays right there by kawhi
leonard i mean nice finish right there
free throw by chris dapps brings it down
to a 10-point advantage for the clippers
nice pass from zoo the kawaii to the rim
counter than a foul and give him
one more on the house the pass was
amazing too
but good finish right there with contact
from two
defenders right there for kawhi leonard
but i agree
that pass right there 12 points and 16
minutes off the bench for rick carlisle
and he's just he's just kawaii leonard
to the best you talk about
when you look at kawhi gets in that
elbow area situation they
cleared out the back side and
[Applause]
kawhi takes it to the rim and smashes it
clipper locker room that's not going on
in every locker room you know and quite
frankly they
they're still kind of getting to know
one another roster having played
a lot together see kawhi leonard get to
the basket for the m1 layup
he's going to continue to be aggressive
but i thought it was a little bit let's
be honest i thought it was a little bit
overblown
strippers can take the lead with a
bucket here kawhi
knocks down the three in traffic
fiornier was right above
leonard against wiggins what a feat
inside oh
what a finish in footwork by landry
shamit watch the delivery
boom slip on time before the defender
down low
him rotate over
[Applause]
kawhi for three and he knocks in his
second triple of the quarter
beverly with a rebound kawhi leonard
but for a moment he'd pull the trigger
on the three and said he wants to flirt
with the defense before he does his
damage
27 for kawhi leonard again led by 13.
andres again great to see him back in
the lineup after twisting that ankle
to close out the first half here's
leonard to the cup with the right hand
love from above quickly and you'll see
kauai
and you're getting out of his way on
that one because it's coming down hard
george tonight so far two for four kawhi
finds a team
drives the lane and powers it in with
the right hand
really beasley going three for five has
certainly helped the cause leonard in a
two-man game with zubots calls his own
number
on johnson counted on a foul he had a
three-pointer
on the last possession now gets an
old-fashioned opportunity here
it was turned down right there he gave
it up you've got a long defender right
in his face
and he still shot it davis for free with
a rainbow
and back tap by lebron another
opportunity leonard for
three kawhi leonard
[Music]
[Applause]
find the practice time to sharpen their
tools
in the final 55 days or so of the season
well
listen first of all it's a good job of
getting kawaii
basketball trying to get him going side
pump you put a single
defender defender nice play right there
by hawaiian
and coach rivers i mean out of bounds
play nice pass
nice finish lou williams back out there
for doc rivers
here's leonard in attack mode a soaring
southpaw spike and the clippers lead
16-4
why i guess that but how about this dunk
right here it must be nice to be able to
move that basketball from one hand to
the other hand
for 11 to open up deflection inside the
leather larceny here come the clippers
leonard doesn't have numbers leonard
doesn't care to the ram
counted on a foul
memphis on the season by the way 6 and
21 when they trail by 10.
it's all systems go for kawhi leonard
and the clippers count it enough
so wait for the screen gets enough off
the body to allow kawhi to get space
and then that's just a high basketball
iq kawhi puts
the ball down just enough so the
defender can reach out in the world
knows he likes to go right
but it's still tough to keep him from
getting there hawaii
for three in the lead counted on a foul
and send him to the line for the
four-point play
opportunity kawhi leonard comes off a
down screen ready to shoot it
these guys have been moving them back
you're talking about the
nba finals teams of the golden state
warriors here's leonardo
puts it down watch the palm
we all know about his hands and then the
finish
we've been seeing him dunk on cats with
his left hand
lately he goes back to his dominant hand
the right hand
and makes a poster with a couple guys
who wants to get in there league
officials tell me that tomorrow the
board of governors will have a
conference call
that will discuss a further plan of
action i've also been told ayan
that team officials for the warriors
have been in constant contact with local
government officials
lost for the lake yeah i agree with you
and avery was here with the clippers
number one not healthy but
and and there are numbers as kawaii
makes a three
i've got great news for you there's been
27 taken so far we still have
nine minutes to play in this first half
leonard
the shooters touch inside the bubble
i'll tell you what kawhi put a little
english this ball sat on the rim for
about
four seconds and dropped in trying to
make it as much as home as they possibly
can
kawhi a step away three and chauncey i'm
going to go on back on my bold
prediction if the clippers don't miss
threes today they win the game he's
about to
human being that he is how great of a
guy he is
well a bad gamble by j.j redick
but she don't see him make undisciplined
defensive play and now
a 10-point lead for phoenix wow
here is leonard on the wing for three
it's good dueling banjos with one point
one to play
here this first i didn't know that he
could put the ball on the floor like he
did
and i didn't know he had the ability to
stay in front of kawhi leonard
leonard a three kawhi leonard is lethal
leonard on the mismatch with allen
surveys the scene
and takes allen straight to the rim
allen becomes leonard's scoring muse
count it and a foul match up that's why
don't set a screen
let me just go to work right here great
finish with the left hand
by kawaii strategy that the nets have of
not missing shots
has paid off so far leonard gets deep
into the paint
shoves it deep in the well with a right
hand blows out the second quarter
leonard for three counting on a foul
really quick shot off of pick and roll
three was
short this one right here comes off of
dribble penetration
nice dribble penetration kawhi catches
the ball he's balanced
he's set chasing joe harris over the
screen and making him shoot a two-point
jump shot leonard feeling good why not
oh
you love to see it clippers are down by
three
so he walks you right into two
three-point shots
he has eight points